house Kung Fu Panda 3 so Kung Fu Panda 3
is the third installment in the
remarkably enjoyable Kung Fu Panda
series in this one po now becomes the
teacher of the mystical art of kungfu
and then he meets his father and finds
out that there are more pandas out
there's the whole panda village so he
goes there to hang out learn the art of
qi meanwhile a big bad spirit warrior
batty named Kai busts out of the spirit
realm now he's on earth and he can steal
warriors Chi and then turn them into
emerald versions of themselves that
fight for him and now he's coming after
the pandas and the only one who stands
in his way is of course the Kung Fu
Panda what I like about these Kung Fu
Panda movies you think after the first
one awry he's gonna learn kung foo now
he knows kung fu then the second one I
thought it was gonna be a bumbling idiot
again and he always is kind of clumsy
always that black sheep of the Kung Fu
world in the Kung Fu Panda movies he
always remembers what he learned before
is just the next step up now he needs to
learn the next thing which never really
wipes the slate of his character clean
he never starts from scratch is always
springboarding off the last one props of
this franchise for that and the villains
have always been great I love the
villains in the first and the second
Kung Fu Panda and this one he takes
souls of warriors turns them into zombie
versions of themselves to fight for him
and he has the blades of chaos from God
of War he's ultimately Shang soon for
Mortal Kombat meets Kratos from God of
War fused into one body this movie
pretty sweet if you ask me me animation
in this movies great is fluent it's
solid it's detailed the kung-fu segments
are really exciting it's just well
animated well executed it's a family
story I mean Kung Fu Panda has always
been a family story but in this one he's
learning how to be a panda so he's
ultimately learning how to be lazy I
feel like this is an element that's
gonna gravitate to adults more because
let me the father who raised him kind of
feels insecure about it when his
biological father comes into the sámi
that's a family dynamic that a lot of
people have seen but you have to be
older in order to have seen it in real
life but when is all going down is
hitting the fan you can't help but just
sit back and be like this Kung Fu Panda
trilogy is a solid trilogy if ever there
was one it's not Toy Story for me but
this is some good stuff with all these
new characters that just bring in all
the Panda characters the original 5 kung
fu masters kind of get left in the
background in this movie except for
tigress she's in it more than the others
but ultimately they're like hey move
aside
make room for the newbies and the first
thing I thought when I walked out of
this movies I felt that there should
have been a one-on-one mano e mono Kung
Fu slam fest I should have happened
between Kai and Po this should have been
kung fu madness one-on-one animated to
his full glory that we've seen this
movie in franchise can do in the end it
was more of a story based resolution so
you didn't really get that but in the
end Kung Fu Panda 3 was solid great
character great build on the already
established character of Po from the
previous movies great animation great
kung fu solid villain take your family
to see it take your kids to see it if
you're a fan of the other Kung Fu Panda
movies shoot you have to watch this this
is dumb ian is a concluding chapter of a
trilogy now is it the last Kung Fu Panda
we're gonna get I don't know probably
not but I love it when a trilogy comes
together and you have a solid one here I
will say Kung Fu Panda 3 is definitely
worth buying on blu-ray I get your
skadoosh is ready guys the Kung Fu Panda
movies have you seen them what did you
think about them what's your favorite
Kung Fu Panda movie whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more Scooby